The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today, we
begin a new topic, which
is parameterized complexity.
This is one of the
most recent areas
of hardness that
has been invented
that we will cover so far.
It started around 1999,
and then since the 2000s,
it's been getting
really big, originally
by Downey and Fellows.
And the general
idea is we're going
to take problems,
which normally we
think of as being parameterized
by the problem size, n,
and thinking about polynomial
versus exponential growth of n.
And we're going to
add another parameter.
So you could say this
is a two parameter
analysis in some sense.
Usually, we call problem
size n and then we
call the parameter k.
In general, a parameter
is just some way
of measuring instances.
So parameter, k, is a
function from instances
to non-negative
integers, 0, 1, 2.
And usually, this number k
is just part of the instance,
for example-- well, let me
go over here to examples.
Let's say problem that's
called k-vertex cover--
and usually, I'll just call it
vertex cover for simplicity.
You know the problem
vertices to cover edges.
And usually, the decision
version of that is
are there k vertices
that cover all edges?
So k is an input
to this problem,
and it appears in the
statement of the problem.
But in particular,
it's an input.
And so this function, k,
of a vertex cover instance
just pulls out that one number
and throws away the graph.
That's the typical parameter.
But in general, a parameter
could be some hard to compute
thing.
Maybe k-- you think
of the parameter--
you take vertex cover
as your problem,
but you define your
parameter to be
the smallest independent set--
or largest independent set.
Smallest is pretty small, 0.
Or, pick your favorite.
You could, for example, think
about vertex cover with respect
to-- this is how we'll write
the parameter-- crossing number.
So the idea here is-- sorry
I forgot to covet-- we always
measure our instances
with respect
to the problem size, which
is the size of the graph
for vertex cover instance.
But we're also going
to parameterize
by some other quantity here.
Maybe it's the minimum
crossing number for your graph,
so 0 if it's planar and so on.
We prove that that's
NP-complete to compute.
So this parameter may not be
easy to compute in general.
But a lot of the times it's
just part of the problem.
And in general, this is called
the natural parameterization.
If you have an
optimization problem,
like vertex cover is--
minimum vertex cover--
and you convert the optimization
problem into a decision
problem, you're asking is
opt less than or equal to k.
That k is the natural parameter
for an optimization problem.
So most the time, we'll
be thinking about that.
But things like this also arise.
So just to be a
little more precise
a parameterized problem
is a decision problem
plus the parameter.
So when I said vertex cover
with respect to crossing number,
I meant my decision
problem is vertex cover,
and I'm going to choose to
use this particular parameter
function to parameterize
those instances.
And in general, we'll call them
parameter k and problem size n.
And our goal is to get a
very good dependence on n
at the cost of a
bad dependence on k.
So let me start with a
so-so dependents, XP, would
be the set of all prioritized
problems solvable in n
to the f of k time for some
function k-- for any function
k, any function f.
And FPT is the set of
parameterized problem solvable
in f of k times
n to the order 1.
So this is considered
a good running time.
This is considered
a bad running time.
F is presumably exponential.
Assuming your
problem is NP-hard,
you have to have
exponential in something.
And the goal is to get the
exponential away from n
because n is hard to control.
We like to solve big problems,
but maybe we can somehow
characterize that the
problems we care about
have some small measure, k--
for some interesting measure k.
If such an algorithm is
possible and, in practice,
your k's are small,
then you're golden.
These give really
good algorithms
for solving lots of problems.
Any problem in FPT, if k
is somewhat reasonable,
even when n is huge, we
can solve the problem.
This running time is also
polynomial for fixed k,
but the polynomial
changes depending on k.
So here, we typically get
linear time algorithms
for any fixed k.
Here, as k increases,
the polynomial
gets bigger and bigger.
And in practice,
you probably can't
handle more than an n squared
algorithm for a large n.
So this is considered not
useful even for small k.
This is considered very
useful for small k,
depending on your notion
of small, of course.
And parameterized complexity,
the main name of the game
is distinguishing between FPT.
And XP is actually rather large,
but distinguishing between when
this is possible and
when it is impossible.
Cool.
So for example,
vertex cover is FPT.
Vertex cover with respect
to crossing number, I think,
is FPT.
I have to think about
that a little bit more.
AUDIENCE: Can you say what
XP and FPT roughly stand for?
PROFESSOR: Oh, right.
FPT is fixed
parameter tractable.
That's the good word.
intuitive--
etymological that means
when you fix the parameter k,
you get a tractable problem
although it's a strong
sense of tractable.
You can say it is n
squared for any fixed k.
Or, it's n to the
fifth for any fixed k.
This constant does
not depend on k.
But the lead constant does.
So that's FPT.
XP, experience points.
Good question.
One other good thing to know.
You might wonder why f
of k times polynomial n.
Maybe I could hope for better
like f of k plus polynomial n.
That actually is the same class.
So FPT also equals the set
of all parameterized problems
solvable in f of k
plus n to order 1.
That's a nice general theorem.
I won't bother proving it here.
I think the f ends up becoming
square of the original f.
It's a very easy case
analysis based on whether
which of these two
things is bigger.
I will leave that
as an exercise.
It would be a good
problem set problem.
Cool, so that answers
one plausible question.
Let me give you an example
of an FPT algorithm,
let's say, for vertex cover.
So back over here
to vertex cover.
How about an XP algorithm
for vertex cover.
So that's really easy,
not very interesting.
You could just guess a vertex
cover, try all possible vertex
covers of size k.
Remember, we want to know
whether there's a vertex cover
size k. k is given
to us, so we could
try all vertex covers--
or, I shouldn't
say that-- all vertex
sets of size k.
There's only n to the k of them.
And for each of them,
we'll spend linear time
to check whether
it's a vertex cover.
So this proves that
the problem is in XP.
That's trivial.
Most problems you'll
find are in XP
with reasonable
parameterization.
On some, it's not obvious.
And now, let's prove
that it's in FPT.
This is a little
more interesting.
There are lots of FPT
algorithms for vertex cover.
It's an active area.
Every year there's a better
algorithm pretty much.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So in the inputs of
the problem, the k is an input?
PROFESSOR: For vertex
cover, k is an input.
AUDIENCE: Oh, because you
can also think of vertex
cover where k is not
an input, but you
can analyze the run time.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Right.
So you could also think about
vertex cover with respect
to vertex cover.
So here, let's say-- this
is a little bit funny,
but here the idea
is k, the parameter,
is the minimum vertex cover.
Let me write minimum
vertex cover.
And here, you're given
some other value.
Let's call it j.
And you want to decide whether
vertex cover is at most j,
but you're not told what k is.
You're not told what
the optimal value is.
So this is a little bit subtle.
It's essentially
the same problem.
You're just not told
the critical value.
But if you can solve k
vertex cover when k is given,
you can just run that
algorithm for k equals 1, 2, 4,
and you'll end up
solving this problem.
So even though--
so in this problem,
you can say, well, if I discover
there's no vertex cover of size
k, I can just return no.
Here, it's a little
more annoying, but just
by iterating and stopping when
you get the first vertex cover,
your algorithm
will end up having
a good running time
with respect to k
even though you didn't know it.
So it's a subtlety.
In general, this is
messy to work with,
so we usually think
about k being an input.
But that reduction shows
they're more or less the same.
But the complexity theory
for this is annoying.
In the same way that for NP, we
restricted decision problems,
here we're going
to usually restrict
to the natural parameter.
So good question.
Let me prove vertex cover is in
FPT, so a much better running
time than n to the k.
I think I will get something
like 2 to the k times n.
Look at an edge of
the graph, any edge.
Pick an edge, any edge.
And we know for this
to be a vertex cover,
one of the two endpoints
has to be in there.
Which one?
I don't know.
Guess.
So I'm going to guess either
the left guy or the right vertex
is in the vertex
cover, and then repeat.
So when I put somebody
in the vertex cover,
I delete all of
the incident edges.
That takes linear time.
Over here, I would
delete whatever
edges are incident to this
guy and the vertex itself,
of course.
And so I get a smaller graph.
I do this k times, so in
general, my execution tree
will have two branches, every
time I pick an edge and say,
do I put the left guy
or the right guy in.
But I only need to worry
about a tree of height k
because after I
make k decisions,
I'm supposed to get a
vertex cover of size k.
After I make k
decisions, if there's
anything left to
the graph that means
that wasn't a vertex cover of
size k and I should backtrack.
So I just explore
this tree, look
at all the different leaves.
If there's any vertex cover
of size k, I will find it.
And so I only spend 2 to
the k to explore this tree.
2 to the k is the size
of the tree times n
because I maybe delete
n things at every node.
And that's one of
the simplest FPT
algorithms for vertex cover.
There are much
cooler, fancier ones.
But this is now going
to be about hardness,
so I will stop with algorithms.
Also related is a
stronger notion of PTAS.
So I mentioned
before, with PTAS, you
could have a running time
something like n to the 2
to the 1 over epsilon--
which is actually
fairly common in a lot
of PTASes, not so great.
If epsilon is anything
good, then this
is going to be a
really huge polynomial.
Well, the corresponding
notion in FPT land
is a running time
of f of epsilon--
or, I'll write 1 over epsilon.
It doesn't matter--
times n to the order 1.
So this is really saying that
the approximation scheme is FPT
with respect to 1 over epsilon.
This is to get a 1 plus
epsilon approximation.
So this is relating
the two worlds.
If you want a FPT algorithm
for approximating a problem
and getting within a factor
of 1 over epsilon, if you
get this kind of
running time verses
this kind of running time, I
consider this good, this bad.
And in general, these are called
Efficient PTASes, or EPTAS.
And in general, if
you have an EPTAS,
you also have an FPT
algorithm with respect
to the natural parameter,
which is to basically compute
what the optimal value is,
because you can let epsilon be
something like 1 over 2k--
that ought to do it-- something
less than 1 over k.
You're trying to
decide whether you
have a solution of less
than or equal to k or not,
whether optimal is
strictly greater than k.
And I said k is an
integer, so this
is an integer valued problem
you're trying to optimize.
And so the difference
became k and k plus 1,
multiplicatively, is about
1 plus 1 over k factor.
It's exactly 1 plus 1 over k.
So if we let epsilon be
smaller than 1 over k,
then to get within a
multiplicative factor of 1
plus 1/2 1 over k,
you actually have
to be within an additive plus
1 of the right answer at k.
So this will decide whether
opt is less than or equal to k
based on whether that
approximation algorithm will
give you something of value
at most k or strictly bigger.
Strictly bigger
would be k plus 1.
So this is particularly
interesting
because it means if a
problem is not in FPT,
then it does not have
an Efficient PTAS.
So we can use-- before,
in previous lectures,
PTAS was considered gold.
Now, we can distinguish
between EPTAS and PTAS.
And there are problems
that have PTASs
that do not have FPT
algorithms assuming
FPT does not equal w1-- an
assumption we will get to
in a moment.
So if you can, in general,
establish something is probably
not in FPT, then we get
it probably does not
have an Efficient PTAS.
So this is useful for lower
bounds about approximation.
Even if you don't care about
fixed parameter tractability,
this will give us cool
things about approximability.
AUDIENCE: Can you give
a few examples of EPTAS?
PROFESSOR: A few
examples of EPTAS.
For example, most of the planar
results I've talked about,
planar independence set, planar
vertex cover, those things all
have Efficient PTASs.
But that gets us into the
world of bounded treewidth
algorithms.
But in general, if you have like
a-- a lot of bounded treewidth
algorithms are FPT.
There will be some exponential
in treewidth times polynomial n
So a lot of times,
you can use those
to get EPTASs for planar
and h-minor free problems.
So that's one set of examples.
There's no short
example I can give you,
but that's a big class.
So for either reason,
either you want
to solve problems
for small k or you
want to figure out
whether there's an EPTAS,
how can we prove that problems
are hard in this world using
reductions like usual?
So in this context,
luckily, there's
only one type of
reduction we need
to learn unlike approximation
where there were a lot.
And I'll call it
parameterized reduction
although throughout this
lecture and the next one
I'll just say reduction usually
because we're always talking
about parameterized problems.
So in general, we have some
problem A-- decision problem A
and parameter k.
And we want to convert into
some decision problem B
with parameter k prime.
And of course, as usual,
the set up is we're
given an instance x.
This is going to look almost
identical to NP Karp-style
reductions, but then we're going
to have one extra condition.
So instance x of
A gets mapped to
by a function f to an
instance x prime of B. X prime
is f o x as usual.
This needs to be a
polynomial time function
just like for NP reductions,
which means, in particular,
x prime has polynomials
size reduced back to x.
It should be answer preserving.
So x is yes instance
for A if and only
x prime is a yes instance for B.
So, so far, exactly
NP reductions.
And then when we
need one extra thing
which is parameter preserving.
This is there's some function
g, which I'll call the parameter
blow up-- or, I guess you
call it parameter growth
for g-- such that
the new parameter
value for the
converted instance is,
at most, that function
of the original parameter
value of the original instance.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Are there any
limits on the amount of time
that g can take to compute?
PROFESSOR: g should be
a computable function.
I think that's all we need.
Probably polynomial
time is also a fine,
but usually this is going to
be like linear or polynomial
or exponential.
It's rarely some
insanely large thing,
but computable would be nice.
Cool.
So that is our notion of
parameterized reduction.
And the consequence,
if this exists
and B is fixed
parameter tractable,
then A is because we can
take an instance of A
converting it to B. If
the original parameter was
founded by some k,
this new parameter
will be bounded by g of k.
New instance will be
bounded of g of k.
So we run the FPT
algorithm for B,
and that gives us the answer
to the original instance of A.
So if we don't care about
what this function is,
we are basically
composing functions.
So there's some f dependence
on k in this algorithm,
and we're taking that function
of g of k is our new function.
And we get a new dependence on
k and the running time over FPT.
So what that means
is if we believe
it A does not have an FPT, then
B does not have an FPT if we
can do these reductions.
So same style, we're
going to reduce
from a problem we know is
hard, A, into a problem
that we don't know about, and
that proves B is hard as well.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is
the relationship
between FPT and XP?
Is there like a difference?
PROFESSOR: Yeah
AUDIENCE: If there's overlap.
PROFESSOR: Well, FPT
is contained in XP.
And they are different if you
believe the exponential time
hypothesis.
If you believe SAT
does not have two
to the little of n algorithms--
if that's not possible for SAT,
then XP and FPT are different,
and much, much more things
are different.
But we'll talk about that
more next class-- relating
to exponential time hypothesis.
So at this moment, we don't
really care what g is.
But if you assume
exponential time hypothesis,
then g matters, and you
can get very explicit lower
bounds about how good an
algorithm you could hope for.
So we won't just prove you're
probably not an-- we won't just
prove you're not an FPT, but we
will give an actual lower bound
and how much running
time you need,
something like n
to the little k.
But the running time we get
will depend on this blow
up function.
So next class, we'll
care about what g is.
So I do try to minimize it,
but so far we don't care.
Any g is fine.
XP will not turn
out to be the class
that we think about very often.
There are things in between that
are a lot easier to work with,
which we will get to.
In particular, W1
is the most common.
So let me do two examples.
One of which is a correct
example and the other is not.
And you can help me
figure out which is which.
Independent set to
vertex cover, these
are reductions
we've seen before.
We have tons of
reductions, but usually we
weren't thinking
about parameters.
And independent set
to clique, these
are basically identical
problems left and right.
And I want the
natural parameter.
Which of these is a parameter
preserving reduction?
I need some quiz show music.
AUDIENCE: The second.
PROFESSOR: The second, yeah.
Because if we take a
graph and a parameter k,
what we convert it to
is the complement graph
with the same parameter.
So that's obviously
parameter preserving.
Whereas independence
set, these are
complementary in
a different sense
that if you take everything
that's not in the independence
set is a vertex cover.
So it's actually the same
graph but with n minus k
as the new parameter.
So this is not a
parameterized reduction.
This is.
And in fact, vertex cover,
we just showed is FPT.
Independence set is not, if you
believe w1 does not equal FPT
or if you believe
exponential time hypothesis.
And that would contradict
this statement.
So this is definitely
not a valid reduction.
But those are some pretty
trivial reductions.
Let's do some more
interesting things.
And I want to start to
introduce the notion of w1.
I won't define w1 yet.
I'd like to wait a little bit
because the definition is not
super intuitive, but here is a
fairly intuitive hard problem
that you should be fairly
convinced is not FPT.
So I'll call this k-step
non-deterministic Turing
machine.
The one downside is I've never
mentioned Turing machines
in this class.
I thought I could
get away without it,
but I'm going to
have mention them.
How many people
know what they are?
Anyone does not?
OK, a couple.
Here's a Turing machine.
I will give you, very briefly,
a very non-standard definition
of a Turing machine.
Let's think of-- so you
have this infinite tape,
infinite memory, and
for our purposes,
these are not just
binary symbols,
you can write up to n different
symbols on each of the squares.
So this is basically
your memory,
but it's in the style of
old-fashioned tape drives
in that you-- In order to get
to position k away from you,
you have to spin k time.
So you can only step
one unit at a time.
And this is basically
computers that we are used to.
So let's say it has a
sequence of instructions,
and it has an
instruction pointer.
And in general, I
want to the machine
to have order n
stateS-- yeah, let's say
order n lines of code and order
n options per cell of the tape.
This will look
actually a little weird
if you're used to
Turing machines,
but I want to use
this definition.
So it's basically a
regular algorithm,
but you're very limited
the number-- in the amount
of internal state.
These are basically
registers, but you
can have only a constant
number of registers
that vary from one to n.
One of them will be what
line of code are you on.
And then you have those lines of
code are instructions like jump
here, compare these things,
write a particular symbol
to the current square of the
tape, move the tape left,
move the tape right.
So regular types of
instructions, let's
say, except you have
this weird tape thing.
Now, I mentioned
these parameters.
And usually we think
of Turing machines
of having constant size,
but here I need an n,
and I need a k.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I was going
to ask what n was.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So n is the input.
I mean basically
the Turing machine
is specified by these things.
You have order n
instructions, and we're
guaranteed there's only order
n possible states, let's say.
And now what we-- and this is
a non-deterministic machine.
Now non-determinism, we
have talked about this
in the context of NP.
A non-deterministic
Turing machine
has a funny
instruction which says
non-deterministically branch
to one of n different locations
in my memory.
Or, let's say choose
a symbol from my-- I
have this alphabet that
I'm using in my cell--
choose a symbol
non-deterministically.
So I have order n choices
made non-deterministically.
In the usual sense of
NP, that if there's
any way for the Turing
machine to output,
yes-- one of the instructions
is output, yes-- then,
I will find it.
These are guesses,
and they're always
lucky guesses, so I always
end up finding the return,
yes, if there is such a path.
Otherwise, all paths return, no,
and then the machine returns,
no.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What does it mean
for the number of states
to change as the input changes?
PROFESSOR: I mean the
states are also given to you
as part of the Turing machine.
There's not one
turning machine-- well,
there is actually one Turing
machine to rule them all,
but that's not the point here.
I give you a machine that has--
think of this as firmware built
into the machine, and the
number of states in the machine
includes which instruction
you're currently executing.
So I mean this is
just saying you're
given an arbitrary machine
of size-- of complexity n.
And usual Turing
machine land, there
are n states because I give you
a state diagram with size n.
So you're given everything
about the Turing machine.
So that is the input
to this problem.
And the question is, can
I find a return, yes,
solution that only
is k steps long.
So I'm given this huge
machine, and yet I
want a very short
execution of the machine.
I want the running time to only
be k. k, again, is parameter.
n is big. k is small.
So I want to know is there a
yes path from the initial state
of length k.
So this is basically--
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Are you given the
input to the Turing machine?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, let's
say it has no input.
Input is all
embedded in the code.
So the tape is initially blank.
Good.
There's a reason I need
to do Turing machines here
instead of usual algorithms,
but if you define-- usually
NP is defined in
terms of these things.
So by analogy to NP, we expect
there are no lucky algorithms.
And so we expect
that when you have
non-deterministic branches,
the best thing you can do
is to try all the branches.
And so if I have an execution
time of k, and at each step,
I can potentially make a
non-deterministic choice
among n different
options, then you
would expect the best
algorithm is n to the k.
Try all the branches, that's
just like our vertex cover
algorithm, but in the bad case
where I have branching factor n
instead of branching factor 2.
So presumably, there's no way to
replace a guess among n options
with a guess among two options.
That's an assumption.
And this problem is w1 complete.
I will to define
w1 a little later,
but for now, just
take this as given.
You could define w1
complete to mean problems
that are reducible via
parameterized reductions
to this problem.
And then we'll get lots
of examples of problems
that are as hard as this.
So a modulo the
annoyance of having
to define Turing
machines, I think
this is a pretty
natural assumption.
It's stronger than
p does not equal NP,
so we would imply that.
So let's do some
simple reductions--
some reductions,
maybe not simple.
So I mentioned this
problem independent set.
That's also w1 complete.
And to prove, first of
all, that it's w1 hard,
I'm going to reduce this
problem to independent set.
So I'm given a Turing
machine and a number k.
I want to convert
it into a graph,
and a number k such
that if there's
an independent set of
size k in that graph,
at most k in that
graph if and only
if there's an accept
path of length at most
k in the Turing machine.
So I'm going to skip
a lot of details
because I've been a little vague
about how Turing machines work,
but the idea is nice.
So my graph is actually
going to consist mostly
of k squared cliques.
The cliques are actually quite
large because this graph has
size n, total size, but
there's going to be k squared
clusters, which are cliques.
Plus cliques, not very many
different cliques, only k
squared of them.
And my target independent
set is size k squared,
which means if there's going
to be an independent set,
I must choose exactly one
vertex from each clique.
So one vertex per clique.
Independence that has to
have no edges among them.
So if I chose two
from a clique, there
would be an edge among
them, that's disallowed.
And so the cliques I'm
going to parameterize
by two parameters i and
j between one and k.
And the idea is that ij
represents memory cell i
at time j plus the
state of the machine.
So what I mean is there are
order n states in the machine,
in general, that
completely characterize
what the machine is about to do
and what it's thinking about,
all of its internal state.
And so I'm just going
to take those n states
and plop them in.
And each node in this clique
represents one of those states.
But also I want to keep track
of what symbol is written
on that square of the tape.
And so, in general,
my running time
is bounded by k-- also the
number of squares I write
to the tape is bounded by k.
Space is at most
time-- so I only
have to worry about k different
cells for times 1 up to k.
So there are only order n
states for this, only order n
states for this.
So the size of each clique is
order n squared polynomial.
That's cool.
It's a messy clique.
I won't try to draw what
it really looks like.
And then the general
approach is I'm
going to add some edges
between pairs of vertices
to say, well look, if this cell
was this thing at this time,
and the state of the
machine was move right,
then you better not change what
was on the cell at that time
because nothing changed.
You weren't here.
So we can just forbid
that by saying,
well, here is one state.
These two states should
be mutually exclusive.
So if I choose this vertex
in an independent set,
I can't choose this vertex.
So you just draw all
these connections
of forbidden things.
If something is true
time i, times j,
then something else should
not be true at time j plus 1.
You draw in all those
connections, and it works.
I'll leave it at that because
the details are messy,
but it gives you some idea.
At this point, I can plug
a book on this topic that
is coming out next year, a
little bit far in the future
but it is-- I didn't write
it down here of course.
Sorry.
It is by these guys again,
Fomin, Kowalik, Lockshtanov,
Marx, Pilipczuck
brothers, and Saurabh.
And it does go through the
details, the gory details.
If you're interested in
that, I could share with you
that section.
But unfortunately, the
book is not released yet.
Cool.
So that was a reduction
to independent set, which
shows the independence
set is at least as
hard as this problem, which
we think is hard, w1 hard.
So that proves w1 hardness.
But there's another question
of is independent set in w1.
As you might guess from the name
w1, there's more than just w1.
There's w2 and w3
and w4 and even more.
And there's no one
notion of hardness
like we had with NP here, so
we get a bit of complexity
in that hierarchy.
But in fact, independent set is
w1 hard-- sorry-- w1 complete.
So we can do a reduction
from independence
set to Turing machine.
Let's say k-step
non-deterministic Turing
machine.
And the idea is pretty simple.
We have k-steps, so let's
guess all the vertices.
You can see here
this is where we
need the ability to guess
among n different options
in each guess step.
So we're given-- we want
to know whether there's
an independent set
of size k, so guess
all those vertices of
size k and then check it.
So this was our XP
algorithm, but now
phrased as a non-deterministic
Turing machine algorithm.
And it's a little bit subtle
what it means to check.
Of course, what we
want to do is make sure
there's no edge between any
pair of the chosen vertices.
So what we're going to do is
when we guess these k vertices,
we're going to write them one
at a time on the tape squares.
So we'll use k tape squares
to store the k vertices
that we've chosen.
Then, we want to check
each pair of them.
So this is like a
doubly nested loop
for each vertex among the k,
for each vertex among the k.
So what that means
is you're going
to have to-- sorry,
that's a little bit
annoying-- loop through
the vertices on one tape.
And then the fun
part is the graph
is encoded inside the machine.
You could think of
there being a data
section within the code that
says where all the edges are.
The graph is size n, and so
you can put the entire graph
into the machine.
And then given two
vertices, you could
check that there is indeed
no edge between them
basically by using the
code as a look-up table.
Say hey, is there a
vertex from i to j.
If yes, then we're in
trouble, abort this option,
try the other guesses.
If you look up in the table
and it says there's no edge,
then you keep going.
So you test all the
pairs, make sure there's
no edge by-- the code, as it
is, is a constant size algorithm
which looks like this
plus an order n size
thing, which is the
look-up table for what
edges are in the graph.
So that part's a
little bit weird.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in case of the k
in k vertices aren't the same k?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
I'm sorry.
This is k prime.
Yes.
So probably k prime here
is exactly order k squared.
Thank you.
It makes me a little happier.
Because I'm doing this
doubly nested loop,
I'm going to have to loop
over this thing several times.
I would look at
the first vertex,
memorize it by reloading
it into a register,
and then loop over all the
other guys for each of them
check that they're bad.
So I'm going to have to go
over the tape k squared steps.
And also n prime is whatever.
We get a machine
that's size-- basically
the size of the graph
V plus E. So the point
of doing that was to
show the independence set
is also w1 complete.
So if you were not happy
with Turing machines,
now you can completely
forget about them.
They are mainly used
here as motivation
for why you should expect
this problem to be hard.
But it's equally difficult from
a parameterization perspective.
If you ignore how
big the blow up is,
it's just as hard as
an independence set.
So independence set
is a problem we think
there's no good algorithm.
And by this reduction, and
also the reverse reduction,
clique is also w1 complete.
So a bunch more reductions.
In general, most w1 hardness
results start from clique.
So that's a good problem to
know about, or independent sets,
I think.
And there are some
simpler versions of clique
that are also hard.
So first one is clique
in regular graphs.
So it's helpful to assume
all the vertices have
exactly the same degree.
Is it hard in three
regular graphs?
No.
Because three regular is
only a clique of size three.
So that's pretty easy.
But in s regular graphs, the
degree is going to be huge,
going to be some function of n.
Clique is hard, and
in general, let's say
capital delta is the maximum
degree in your given graph,
and we want to convert it
into a delta regular graph.
So we're going to increase all
the lower degrees up to delta.
What we're going to do is take
delta copies of the graph.
So for every old vertex,
we get delta copies of it.
And then we do this reduction.
So the blue is the original--
is the graph that's
been duplicated delta times.
Here, delta is 5.
But suppose, in the
graph, this vertex
only had degree 3, some
number less than 5.
Then, what we're
going to do is create
delta minus d new vertices
and then add a biclique here,
bipartite clique, connecting all
of those delta minus d things
to all of these delta things.
They're delta copies
of the original vertex.
This is v over here,
v1 through v delta.
And so what that means
is these vertices
will have entered degree delta
because there were delta things
to connect to over there.
And now these things
will have degree delta
because they used
to have degree d,
and now they have
an additional degree
delta minus d on the left.
So cool, everything's
now delta regular.
And I claim that this
reduction preserve cliques
because if you look at
these added vertices,
they do not belong
to any triangles.
This thing here is an
induced bipartite graph,
and so there are no
triangles, no things of size--
no cycles of size 3 because
all cycles are even here,
which means if
you're in a clique--
if you have three
guys in a clique,
then they better have
triangles everywhere.
So if you put one of
these vertices in,
you'll have a very small
clique, namely size 2.
And there are always cliques
of size 2 in a graph.
There's at least one edge.
So if there was at
least one edge before,
afterwards, we do not increase
any of the clique sizes.
So clique size is preserved.
Everything's cool.
So in this situation
k prime equals
k when you blow up anything,
except the graph size,
of course.
That got a little bigger.
And now everything's
delta regular.
Le me give you an example
of why this is useful.
Of course, every time I say
something is true of clique,
it's also true of
independence set.
You can just flip things.
Here, we have to be
a little careful,
but when you complement
a graph, if you
started with a regular
graph, your new graph
will also be regular.
Every vertex would
have degree n minus 1
minus delta or n minus
delta, something like that.
So here's another problem,
eerily similar to vertex cover,
called partial vertex cover.
This is also w1 complete.
We want to know, can I choose
k vertices that cover l edges?
So usually vertex cover, you
need to cover all the edges,
and that let us do some
crazy things because whenever
we looked at an edge, we
knew one of the two things
was in the vertex cover.
Now, we don't know that anymore.
Now, it's a matter
of which vertices get
the most bang for your buck.
And this is easy to reduce from
delta regular independence set
because-- k independence set
if we want to be explicit.
We want to know is there an
independent set of size k.
I just give that to
partial vertex cover
with k prime equal
to delta times k.
Sorry, that's l prime
is delta times k.
So the idea is here I want
to choose k vertices that
are independent.
And if I can do that, I will be
able to choose k vertices that
cover exactly
delta times k edges
because if they're
independent, none of the edges
will be shared among
my independence set.
And this is if and only if.
If I try to choose k vertices
that cover exactly delta k
edges, then they
can't be adjacent.
The vertices can be adjacent.
So these problems become
the same under this mapping,
so I didn't even blow up.
My parameter here is k.
I forgot to mention.
I mean you could guess from the
letter, but parameterized by k,
this problem is w1 complete.
Parameterized by l,
this problem is FPT.
So be a little careful.
But here's the reduction for k.
There is no reduction
for-- there's only
good reductions for l.
So there we are clearly using
that the graph was regular.
Otherwise, it would be
at most k-- at most delta
for everybody, and
then it's hard to get
the actual independence.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I'm
still a bit confused
about the relationship
between w1 and XP and FPT.
I don't know what w1 is.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
well we'll get there.
For now, you can think
w1 is all problems they
can be parameterized, reduced to
k-step non-deterministic Turing
machine.
That's a fine definition.
Some people use that.
And in general, FPT
is contained in w1.
It's contained in other
things, which we will get to.
w2 and so on is all
contained in XP.
And these are strict if you
believe exponential time
hypothesis.
So if you believe there are
no sub exponential algorithms
for SAT, then this problem has
no FPT algorithm with respect
to k and all the
w1 complete things.
I mean from a complexity
theory standpoint,
it will be fun to look
at these larger classes.
From is there an FPT
algorithm standpoint,
all you care about
is it's not here.
And any hardness,
w1 or worse, will
imply there's no FPT
algorithm if you assume ETH.
AUDIENCE: Do you know if any
of these inclusions are strict?
PROFESSOR: Like I said,
they're all strict
if you assume exponential
time hypothesis.
If you prove XP is
different from FPT,
then you prove P does not
equal NP, I think, pretty sure.
So we're not going to
non-categorically say
these things are strict, because
these are all stronger versions
of P does not equal NP.
But if you believe
exponential time hypothesis,
then they're all strict.
So that's one
standard assumption
that gives us everything.
Cool, let me give you another
version of clique that's hard.
Mufti-colored clique if you
remember way back to three
partition, we had a
variation on three partition
called numerical
three-dimensional matching
where you had to choose
your triples from three
different sets.
So this is the analog
of that, or the analog
of three-dimensional
matching where
you had three different
sets of vertices.
For clique here, set
the vertices partition
into k clusters.
And the question is, is there
k clique with one vertex
per cluster?
And in fact, so you think of
these things as being colored,
color 1, and these
are color k and so on.
And in fact, we can assume
this is a proper coloring
because if you're not allowed
to choose two vertices from one
class, then there's no reason
to have edges between vertices
of the same color.
So this is in fact a
k-coloring of the graph.
So we are given a k-color graph.
And we want to know,
does it have a k clique?
And if it has a d clique
and it's k-colored, then
in particular, you will
have exactly one vertex
per color class.
We can prove this is hard
by a reduction from clique.
Namely, if we have
a vertex v, we're
going to make k copies of it.
You'll see this
is a common trick.
And we will color
them 1 to up to k.
So good, now we have
vertices in each color class.
And then if we have an edge
(v,w) convert it into edges
(vi, wj) for all
i not equal to j.
So pretty much the
obvious reduction.
Once you said make k copies,
we'll also duplicate the edges
in all versions except, because
it's supposed to be a k-color,
we're not allowed
to connect (vi,wi).
But otherwise, we'll just
throw in all of those edges.
And the point is this,
again, doesn't really
blow up your cliques
because if you
have some clique
in this structure,
you can just forget
about the i indices.
Because you know
it's a clique, you
will never choose two
verses from the same color
class, two vertices
with the same index,
and so you can take any
clique here and collapse it
to a clique here.
Conversely, if you
have a clique here,
you can just assign those
vertices arbitrary numbers
as long as they're all
distinct any permutation of one
through k, and you'll
get a clique down here.
So it's the same problem.
Question?
AUDIENCE: That v is different
from the v above it, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this is
for all v and for all vw.
If there's an edge in the
graph, then we do that.
And if there's a vertex
in the graph, we do that.
Cool.
So k prime here equals
k, no expansion.
This may seem trivial,
but it's actually
a fairly recent innovation to
think about multicolor clique
and, in general, it
simplifies proofs.
I have heard of proofs
simplifying from tens of pages
to one page.
We'll probably get to
some more-- to such
sophisticated example soon.
But I can give you
one simple example.
Before I get to
a simple example,
I want to show
you a fun example.
Not simple, but let me tell
you what the problem is.
I won't cover that proof.
The problem is shortest
common super sequence.
This is a problem that comes
up in computational biology.
Your given k strings.
Let's say alphabet sigma.
And yes, you're given a number,
which I'm going to write l.
You want to find
a string of length
l that's a super sequence
of all input strings.
So maybe you're given the
DNA sequence of human and DNA
sequence of mouse,
and you want to know
what is the shortest
DNA sequence that
contains all of the
letters of those strings
in the correct order.
So this is often
called an alignment.
If you have ACGG--
this is probably not
valid, but whatever--
And we have
some other guy like CAGGAT.
So I tried to draw
those aligned.
So then the common super
string here is ACAGGACT.
This is a super string,
meaning I can drop letters
from down here and get this.
Or, I can drop letters from
down here and get this.
That was for k equals 2.
In general, this
problem does have
an n to the k dynamic program.
But the question is whether
you could get FPT in k.
Could you get a small dependence
on the-- better dependence
on the number of strings?
And the answer is no
because this is w1 complete.
And this is a
sketch of the proof.
it's a reduction for
a multicolored clique.
I think this the paper that
introduced multicolored clique
in fact.
It's the earliest one I
could find, and this is 2003.
It became more
popular since 2009.
So you're basically
encoding the edges
by whether there's a 0 here
in between a huge set of ones.
And then this is intuitively
rep-- and then for every vertex
you're looking at, all
of the other vertices
and encoding whether they
have an edge to them.
And so if you have
a clique, that
will be a pattern
that you see repeated
among multiple vertices.
And so you'll end up
being able to shrink
your longest-- your shortest
common super sequence.
But the details are messy.
It's a few pages to prove it.
I will skip that
and tell you why
I wanted to tell you
about this problem
other than its computational
biology and useful.
Because it's used to prove
that flood-it is hard.
Time for some fun.
So here is flood-it.
You have a grid of
colored squares.
And in the top left,
we have colors.
And this is the special square.
What I can do is control
the color of that square.
So for example, I
could set it to red
and then anything that was
in that connected group
becomes red.
And now I've got a
bigger connected group.
So now I can make it blue,
and then pink, and then red,
and then blue, and then red.
Let's see how well I can do.
And the trouble is I have
a limited number of moves.
So this is a model for Ebola
virus spreading or zombie
infection or pick your favorite.
I mean you imagine these are
different species-- green.
Thank you.
A lot easier to play
when I have an oracle.
Yellow, that's better.
I don't know.
I'm actually doing
pretty well here.
I think now I just
have to do them all.
I made it!
25 moves.
Wow!
Felicitations!
That's the first time I've won.
It's a good demo.
Only played a few times,
but-- this apparently
became quite popular in 2006,
a company called LabPixies,
since bought by Google.
But there's tons
of free versions
out there you can play.
It's w1 complete with respect
to number of colors and number
of leaves.
So I don't know if this
is a generalization
or specialization, but it's a
variation of the problem that's
been studied.
It's the only one
I could can that
talked about parametrized
complexity of flood-it.
And so this is
flood-it on trees.
So same set up, but instead
of being a square grid graph,
I'm on a tree graph.
And the root of the tree
is the one I can control,
and my graph is going to
look like-- my tree is
going to look like this.
These are going
to be my strings.
And if I want to be
able to solve this
in some number of
moves, l moves,
then I need to-- the
sequence of colors
I do is a longest common
subsequence, super sequence,
of these strings because they
all have to get to the bottom.
They'll sit there and wait,
and so you can essentially
drop letters.
And that's cool.
Happy?
This is not literally
true because if I have,
let's say, a zero and a zero
here, both the same color--
So I'm representing
letters by colors,
then when I play-- if I
eventually play here and play
zero, I actually get advanced
two spaces instead of one.
So for that, you need to
first map every letter a.
So let's say in string
i, we map every letter
to a followed by a special
character for that string.
And so this blows things up.
In particular, it blows up l.
l grows by a factor
of the total length
of all strings because of
all these things that we add.
These are not
really compressible,
but it means that we alternate
between regular characters
and special characters.
And therefore, we never
have two characters
in a row that are the same.
So first you take
this problem, then
you reduce it to the
version of the problem that
has no repeated characters.
And then you can reduce that
to flood-it because that's
what we care about.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, what's the
parameter on the shortest
common super--
PROFESSOR: Right.
Parameter is-- they're
actually two parameters,
so this is a fun
thing, k and sigma.
So two parameters,
you can think of that
as being parameterized
by the sum or just
by the vector k, sigma.
Basically, we get to assume both
of them are relatively small.
We could be exponential
in both k and sigma.
If you put l in there,
it would not be hard.
But if you put k and sigma
and it's still w1 complete.
And so over here it's
the number of leaves
in the tree is one parameter
and the number of colors
is the other parameter.
So we're fixed parameter
tractable with respect
to that joint parameter.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why is it obvious
that you can reduce flood-it
on trees to not flood-it?
PROFESSOR: It's not
obvious that the grid
problem is related to trees.
There are hardness results
for like 2 by n flood-it.
But they're just NP hardness.
I didn't see a w1 hardness
for 2 by n flood-it.
So as far as I
know, 2 by n colored
is hard-- is open from a
parameterized complexity
standpoint.
Cool.
I want to do one more
reduction, and then I'll
finally define w1.
Dominating Set, this problem
is actually w2 complete,
so this is even harder.
But before we worry about w2,
let's prove that it's w1 hard.
So we're going to reduce
from multicolored clique
to dominating set.
I have a nice figure.
This is a preview of this cool
parameterized algorithms book.
So I'm going to represent
each-- got it right.
Yeah, funny.
I'm going to
represent each vertex
in the multicolored
independence set problem
by a vertex in the
dominating set problem,
so vertices mapped to vertices.
This is the joy of
multicolored cliques.
We did all this k
duplication stuff
once so that we don't have to
duplicate our graphic anymore.
We just take this graph.
We poured it over.
Now, what that tells us is that
the vi's form color classes.
And what I'm going to do is
connect each color class.
So this is the set of
all things of color one,
set of all things of color two.
First of all, I'm going to add
2 dummy vertices to each color
class just to hang out there.
And then I'm going to connect
everything in the color class
by a clique.
Before we only had edges
between color classes,
but now I want to color--
I'm going to also
change those edges.
But the vertices
mapped to vertices,
I add two vertices
of each color,
and then this circle represents
that there's a clique in here,
clique in here, clique in here.
Now, my goal is to
find a dominating set.
And so the intention
is that you need
to choose one vertex
from each color class
in the dominant set.
And that's actually what these
dummy vertices are doing.
They are only going to be
connect to things in here.
They have to be
covered by somebody,
so that means you have to
choose someone in this clique.
You have to choose
someone in this clique.
When you do, it covers
everybody in there.
And there's going to
be no point of choosing
these dummy vertices because
they're only connected
to other things in the clique.
You might as well
choose these things.
Now, how do I represent an edge
in my independence set graph.
If I have an edge
between say u and v,
that's in this color class
and this color class.
We know they're in
different color classes
by multicolored
clique property--
multicolored independent
set property.
Sorry, same thing.
So I want to not
choose both u and v.
So I'm going to represent
that by adding a vertex here,
which must be dominated,
and connect it
to everyone except u over
here and everyone except v
over here, the red patches.
So there are edges from this
vertex to every red vertex
here and here.
So what that means is
if I don't choose u,
I will cover this added vertex.
If I don't choose v, I will
cover this added vertex.
So I will cover it as long as
I don't choose both u and v.
So it's like I should choose
at most one of these two guys,
then this will be
covered for free.
And it has to be covered
for free because we just--
if I set k prime to be the
number of color classes, which
is k, then I don't
have any flexibility.
I can't choose any of
these vertices to dominate.
And so that simulates
independence using dominating
set, pretty simple and clean.
So that gives you a
flavor of nice reductions
you can do with multicolored
clique or independence set.
AUDIENCE: What's
two extra vertices?
PROFESSOR: Why two?
AUDIENCE: The two
you added, it looks
like are not adjacent so--
AUDIENCE: Oh, so
we derived them.
PROFESSOR: Right We want
them to be there in order
to force choosing
somebody down here,
but we don't actually want
to choose one of them.
And so we emit that edge
so if you choose one,
you don't cover the other.
Thanks.
I think it simplifies
the argument.
It's probably not
necessary because I
think you could argue
by replacement argument
that you won't choose
them, but anyway.
Time for some definitions.
I wanted to do some fun problems
before we got to the somewhat
weird definitions.
The time has come.
By the way, dominate set is
w2 complete, so is set cover.
And most w2 hardness reductions
start from one of these two.
We already know how to reduce
dominating set to set cover.
You make a set for every
neighborhood set in the graph.
So this reduction
is easy, and that
preserves a parameter so just
from the same reduction we
did two classes ago, I think.
Here is a problem which
will look familiar,
but under a slightly
different name.
This is what I might
call circuit ones.
One's meaning you want to
set some number of the inputs
to be one, just like our
optimization version.
In this universe, it is
called weighted circuit set.
I'm not a fan of
weighted because there
aren't actual weights here.
The goal is to get
minimum hamming weight,
meaning the minimum number
of ones in your input.
So I give you a circuit-- I'll
draw a very simple circuit,
and it has one output.
It has some number of inputs.
My goal is to set k
ones and get a one out.
Did I do it?
I did it!
! wasn't even looking.
So that's an example of
an input and an output
to weighted circuit set.
The parameter here, k, is the
number of ones, one inputs.
So the question
is can you satisfy
a circuit using only k ones.
That's weighted circuit set.
This problem defines
the class called WP.
This is the original
definition of WP
is all problems that reduce
to weighted circuit set
in a parameterized
reduction sense.
It's all parameterized
problems that
reduce to weighted circuit set.
I lost my hierarchy.
But this is even bigger
than all the things.
So we have FPT is
contained in w1.
It's contained in w2, et cetera.
And then we have WP,
and then we have XP.
So it's not bigger
than everything.
It's not bigger than XP.
I won't prove this
here, but it is true.
Now, I want to
specialize this problem.
I'm going to simplify it
using a notion called weft.
So first the depth
of the circuit,
this is the longest path.
That's a normal notion.
Then, the weft of a circuit
is the maximum number
of big gates on an
input to output path.
Big gates means let's
say more than two inputs.
In general, it's more than
some constant number of inputs,
but two is fine because if you
use a bunch of two input gates,
you can build a ten input gate.
But there's a distinction
between constant input gates
and super constant input gates.
So if you count how many
super constant input gates
you need in a constant
depth circuit,
then we get the w
classes, w for weft.
w(t) is the set of
parameterized problems
that reduce to constant depth
weft-t weighted circuit set.
t is not the parameter.
K is still the parameter.
k is the number of ones.
t is the thing.
Let's do some examples.
AUDIENCE: Depth has to be
larger than weft numbers?
PROFESSOR: Yes, depth is
always larger than weft.
So we allow-- so t
is a fixed constant.
Depth could be 100
times t or something.
AUDIENCE: Then, w in WP is
a different w than w(t)?
PROFESSOR: They both
have to do with weft,
but that's the P
is a polynomial.
It corresponds to
polynomial weft, which
is basically unbounded weft.
w does not stand for weighted.
In both cases, it
stands for weft.
What is weft?
Weft is the opposite of warp.
When you're weaving,
you've got the warp threads
and then you've got this weft
thread that goes back and forth
and ties the whole
circuit together.
So that's sideways,
so if you imagine
that constant input gates do
not need a weft to hold them in,
but super constant ones do, then
it's how many layers of wefting
do you have to do to
cover all those things?
That's the larges the longest
path in terms of counting
the-- that's the term, OK?
But it's actually fairly
useful to think about.
So for example, independence
set, inputs are up here.
Output is down here.
I need to choose,
for each vertex,
whether it's in the
independent set.
And if I negate them, then
I need various constraints.
This is the graph that's
being represented.
I want to say either
I don't choose this
or I don't choose this.
And then all of those
clauses must be true.
That's the and of those things.
This is big.
These are not big.
They have two inputs.
This has one input.
So these are all free.
And then we just do one
in terms of the depth
here where there's one
level of big gates.
So independent set is in w1.
That's a proof that it's in w1.
So that proves all the things
we've been talking about,
except dominating set, is in w1.
Now dominating set,
you need two levels.
So we have the a constraint.
So this is saying that
a should be covered.
a is adjacent to a, b, and c.
I mean if I choose a, b, or
c, then a will be dominated
by the definition of
dominating set because a
is adjacent just to b and c.
But also if I choose
a, then it's dominated.
So this is an or of
those three things.
And a should be dominated,
b should be dominated,
c should be dominated.
So it's an and of
all those things.
But if we don't
have bounded degree,
which we can't because
this problem is
easy for bounded degree, then
we have two levels of big gates.
So this problem is in w2.
Now, funnily enough, w1 and
w2 are the most common things
you see.
I've never seen
a paper about w3.
Some statement, I
think, about problems
that we tend to care about,
ands of ors are common.
This, of course,
CNF SAT is in w2.
I should say weighted
It's actually w2 complete.
Weighted three
set is w1 complete
because things of size 3 are OK.
We can split those into
two things of size 2.
So in general, order one
SAT, you have five SAT.
That's w1 complete.
And CNF SAT is w2 complete.
And I think most of the
problems we care about
can be expressed as--
this should be weighted.
I'm going tow rite w,
but I mean weighted.
But this is a
capital W, different.
That's weft.
So fine that's-- and most of the
problems we care about can be
represented as CNF SAT.
I think that's why we
rarely get outside of w2.
But there are
other things there.
You could do an or of ands of
ors or an and of ors of ands.
Now, we know such formulas
can be converted into CNF form
and only get a
polynomial blow up.
What's going on?
Well, when you do
that inefficient form,
you add extra variables.
When you add extra
variables, you are no longer
preserving the weight.
It would not be a
parameterized reduction.
So if you're just caring about
satisfiability, that's fine.
But if you're considering
weighted satisfiability,
you want to minimize
the number of ones,
it totally changes when
you convert to CNF.
So it matters.
One more fun result, if you
look at 2-tape non-deterministic
Turing machines--
the reason I had
to define 1-tape
non-deterministic Turing
machines is because
they're different
from 2-tape non-deterministic
Turing machines.
These are w2 complete.
The k-step version of 2-tape.
2-tapes is you have 2-tapes
that can advance independently.
Or, you can think of there
are two fingers you can
independently move on one tape.
Those are equivalent,
and they give you w2.
Three tapes, gives w2.
Any constant number of
tapes, you still get w2.
And this is another, I
think, natural reason
why w2 comes up a lot.
I have seen problems that are
hard for what's called w-star.
This w-star is wt
for all fixed t.
You can think of
that as w order a.
So it's the same thing.
So I've seen problems that
don't depend on what t is.
They're hard for all of them.
But I've never seen a
w3 complete problem.
Maybe we can think of one.
I've also seen WP come
up, and there's also
a problem called W-SAT which
is if you have weighted formula
sat instead of weighted circuits
sat, you get w-sat instead WP.
I think it's a little weaker
because in circuit SAT you can
reuse things and in
formula set, you can't.
And it turns out to give
slightly different classes.
So things are messier here.
But if you just care
about whether a problem is
fixed parameter tractable,
these are all bad.
But the point of knowing
about them is you
want to know if your
problem-- first you
should check where it
fits in the w hierarchy
by just thinking about what's
a trivial way to write it down
in the CNF style thing.
Figure out whether
it's w1 or w2.
Then, you'll know which
problems you should start from.
If it's w1, probably want to
start from a version of clique.
If it's w2, you
probably want to start
from a version of
dominating set.
That's why we talked
about them here.
And usually it's w1 or w2.
Cool.
Questions?
We'll do more next time.
This is a fun area.
And next time we'll talk
about, in particular,
how the exponential time
hypothesis relates to all this.